it's easy to embrace hopelessness
when things seem insurmountable it's
actually just a matter of time until all
the elements come together for things to
be all right i mean i believe that most
difficult
situations will resolve themselves if
you are persistent and if you don't
give up entirely
faith is a belief in things that you
cannot see
and sometimes when you can't see no way
that's when you really got to have faith
because that's what it is if you could
see it
you wouldn't have to have faith so all
you got to do then you wouldn't need
faith all you need is patience
it took me 28 years to get on tv
but it happened at an appointed time i
just never gave up the faith
i kept going because i ain't know how to
quit
you you can't quit man
you got to stay with it it's somebody
having it way harder than you and they
didn't give up
you have to believe when you don't see
no way how
you have to buckle down and keep
believing
write down at least five reasons
on why you deserve your dream
and why you won't give up
what's going to make you unstoppable
why you must be unreasonable because
logical practical thinking says you
can't do it today but if you want to
produce
unreasonable results in your life like
living your dreaming taking charge of
your destiny you've got to be an
unreasonable person
if you know why you're doing something
when the hard times come and they're
going to come
when the disappointments and rejections
come and they're going to come by the
truckloads
your reasons will be your rod and staff
to comfort you to pick you up
and the truth is that our dreams are
always there and they don't ever give up
on us we give up on them
but here's the secret
if you just force yourself to take a
couple small steps there's always a
surprise
there's always a surprise waiting if you
take a step off the porch there's a
starry sky there's a great new business
venture there's the marriage and the
juicy sex partner that you wanted
there's whatever you could possibly
imagine so i want you to think about
what are your dreams
i don't care how dog can look for you
i don't care what they just said to you
i don't care what the verdict is i don't
care what the haters say
i think the biggest disability that we
have as human beings is unbelief
just in there
my cookie jar has
every single failure and success of my
life and i think i'm the hardest guy in
the world you got to believe that you
got to believe you are something
i will in my mind
reach into my cookie jar and sometimes
you forget how hard you are in times of
of need
you because you're you're stressed
but you forget i'm like a navy seal i'm
a ranger i'm this and that but you
forget all that cause your life sucks
i calm down take that one second get
control of my life
[Music]
reach in the cookie jar
well you got caught your whole life and
you're now the only person in history do
this this and this
put it back in the cookie jar reset my
mind you have to remind yourself of how
badass you really are
in times of need
that's the [ __ ] cookie jar
that's one temptation here right that's
the temptation of a kind of faithless
hopelessness an army you might say
existential angst that you allow to
pervade yourself and i'm not saying you
won't have your reasons
because you will i'm saying that the
reasons don't justify the conclusion and
they certainly don't justify the
conclusion everybody kept coming up to
me and saying okay you're going to have
stages of grief when you retire you're
going to go into a state of depression
when you retire
and those are all normal and then my
competitiveness inside was like no
i'm going to do something in the next 20
years that is better than these last 20.
you might not understand that i'm doing
that
so the competitiveness kicks in
and the first qualities
of a warrior is courage
you want to live your life from now on
with courage
that most people take their talents
abilities and skills to the grave with
them because of
lack of courage and courage is not the
lack of fear
courage is a willingness to do what it
is you need to do what you are called to
do in spite of the fear
[Music]
you don't want to live a fear-driven
life do you know man that you can
actually mess your life completely up
you can jack it all the way up
and you can turn around get it right
you have a great life in front of you
but your great life is in front of you
it's not behind you
when you get to the edge
your brain will always tell you step
back it's always going to tell you to
step back
because you can fall because before you
fail
the last time you did this you saw
someone else fail you could hurt you
could be off work it's going to tell you
it's designed to keep you safe
so you have to be willing to play
between your brain and your soul
and on some days you got to just listen
to your soul and you got to say i'm a
leap i'm going to get to the edge most
people are at the edge and you're
sitting at the edge and you're watching
everyone else fly
if you can just keep believing
when nothing in you
is working when all your external
forces have given way if you can
just manage to somehow keep hoping
just hope
you ain't really got to believe all you
got to do is hope
faith is the substance of things hoped
for
and the evidence of things not seen you
just got to hope sometimes you ain't
strong enough to believe
but you can always be strong enough to
just hope i'm going to fight i'm going
to work i'm going to press tour i'm
going to learn i'm going to do
everything in my power every single day
i'm going to do everything in my power
to become a victor and not a victim
every victorious person has felted the
urge
to quit
don't you give up on your dream
i don't care if you don't have the money
you don't have the help
and you don't have the family for it and
you don't have the background for it and
you don't have the friends for it don't
you give up on your dream don't you do
it don't you do it don't you do it
it may take you twice as long
you may have to take courses and classes
you might not read as fast you might not
move as quick you might not have as much
but don't you quit
don't you quit
don't you quit you do make a difference
[Music]
you see muscle
muscle is created by repeatedly lifting
things that have been designed to weigh
us down so when your shoulders feel
heavy stand up straight lift your chin
hell call it exercise remember that life
is a gym membership with a really
complicated cancellation policy remember
that you will survive remember things
could be worse remember we are never
ever given anything that we can't handle
when the world crumbles around you you
have to look at the wreckage and then
build a new one out of all the pieces
that are still here remember you are
still here the human heart beats
approximately 4 000 times per hour and
each pulse each throb each palpitation
is a trophy engraved with the words you
are still alive
you are still alive
act like it